today we look at perimeter which is how
does a fine perimeter I would start off
with the leg now yeah okay there's a
couple of different ways to say it is it
right um you could say the length of all
the sides of shape like that all sizes
so for instance let's think about some
of the shapes we know let's go for sweat
yeah I'll get to the second a second so
draw for me a little square doesn't have
to be huge here's a square now we'll get
to the segmentation
don't forget what is it that makes a
square a square all the sides are equal
but there's got to be more than that
because I can have a shame with all four
sides equal but not a sweat and there's
a well something about the owners of the
corner there all right angles so if you
like a square is a rectangle and a
rhombus at the same time setting it with
a square is a rectangle it's got all
this right angles right but all the
sides are equal like a rhombus so if
you've got both of the same time
so I think they generally call the side
legs you know something like say s for
side okay you can see those dashes or
what indicates they're all the same
okay so what's the perimeter P of this
shape there are four sides right so it's
going to be
yeah okay I'll let up at the forefront
we generally put the numbers in front
for s just for ya four times s for lots
of us now that works the length of all
the sides of shape that's fine okay we
could do another similar kind of polygon
the rectangle which we just mentioned
right the rectangle is different because
they're not all equal to each other so
it's just a little bit different the
straw for yourself a little rectangle
okay now what do we usually call beyond
the two different pairs of sides usually
call them neighbors they're all parallel
I sort of talking about like I called
these old s what do we tend to call
these I don't know we usually call one
of them L I call this one L right uh
what I call the other one usually ah hmm
now you can either have W for width
right or you might also see B for breath
now I always got confused as to which
one is which is subsets it doesn't
matter but I think a brie beef bread as
in like broad sounds like our swords
broad shouldered which is how far across
they are from
let me clock ah that's an elf
yeah so now I put I put it I'll make it
weekly because if I did my L like that
what you can't tell if it's one or not
so that's how I am I ain't gonna like it
you mean like a capital L well I suppose
you quick I suppose you could it's kind
of a kind of a tradition or a
conventional a journeys no kidding
alright now this is a rectangle right so
the opposite side as I've got the beer
they're equal but opposite sides are
equal so that makes this one over here
oh yeah right yes and it makes this one
up here also W or B okay so if the
perimeter is the length of all the sides
of shape then I could say the perimeter
is equal to two lots of the length
double the length
okay so 2l cause there's two of them on
each side right and two on the win now
do you remember back to algebra early
this thing we can factor out you don't
have to but it's kind of neat because
you've got two twice so rather write it
twice
you can just say - how do we factorize
it out what's going to be left in the
middle it will just be length plus width
okay so you can see how that - is sort
of a shortcut for saying it twice okay
that's the brand okay now this is great
previous length of all the sides of sure
it works here okay but there's a shape
where it breaks down and I didn't ask
you to bring a country theme but see how
well you can draw for yourself a
circular okay so that'll have to do okay
so a circle the problem with this
definition which has been pretty good so
far
and it's a nice way to think about it is
that a circle has a center and it has a
circumference but it doesn't have sides
right yeah it's got its got a radio so
let's let's draw that in because that's
actually kind of important our radius is
the distance from the center to any
point of the circumference in fact
that's what makes a circle make a circle
a circle that the distance wherever you
measure it will always be the same yeah
we could have ruined October all right
now being that there are no signs it's
all I get to take a look at this bit and
add it to this bit and this maybe this
bit because you've been doing it forever
it's not like the others four or five or
even five billion there are no sides
okay so will there a better definition
than this perimeter is not just the
length of all the sides of the shape
okay I think a are another sort of
helpful definition for this is proven it
is the length around a shape I like both
of these definitions but I think the
second one is a little more helpful to
us okay because it's still saying the
same things here how far is the length
around this shape well you just go all
the way around the same with this but it
works here where even when you don't
side it works you just go all the way
around so the primitive here we said it
gets a special name
it's the circumference
okay you can't call it c4 circumference
is there one know what the circumference
of a circle is war now don't forget
we're talking about legs here not angles
right this angle PR around there we were
looking eggs before that's 360 degrees
but that's an angle that's like how far
you turn right but I want I want a leg
around through the edge right in
centimeters now kind of depends on how
big it is right yeah Krishna player
okay now the answer is it's 2pi but what
does that mean
okay well close a number pi is a number
3.1415 etcetera okay so you go 2 times
that number and then if you multiply by
the radius that would give you the
distance around okay wonder why that is
the radius is always about six times
smaller than the circumference and you
can prove it by bedre if you like you
get a piece of string in government but
um this foil is just what you want okay
I can I can show you some more slides if
you like but I want out one last thing
well I see yeah question
yeah okay sure right well here's an
experiment for you okay your circles
right uh all I assume different sizes
and they're different to mine and I
could draw a whole bunch of different
circles you know I can draw another one
that's smaller I could do one of this
begun on mr. Taylor then you get the
idea
looks like we're doing actually I can do
a whole bunch of different circles okay
now my first one is best
I'm suggesting right I mean you can kind
of see as a circle gets bigger the
circumference and the radius also both
get bigger they're both getting with it
so for instance here's my radius here is
like a little small radius they're the
same way there's a sort of small
circumference okay and it gets bigger
and then bigger and then bigger they
both get bigger together now how can we
try and get you know how close they are
to each other
as one gets bigger the other gets bigger
you can make you can actually get a rule
out you say what's this radius here I
mean what does it look like actually
yeah about 15 I'd say okay and then you
can get a piece of string you can
stretch it all the way around you can
see what you get you get about 19 cent
of it bit over okay if you like you to
measure string out there cut it and then
laid it out straight and then put that
next to a robot probably not this one
because it's a super cross of doing it I
don't I don't even know how I got it but
that's it that's cuz you know that
monster something right okay now you can
do the same thing with water right you
can say well okay what's the radius of
this thing measure it I know that much
more like 10 okay and then take this
thing cut it off and then lay it out
straight and see what you get okay
each time you can do it over and over
again you're going to get the
circumference about six point three
times bigger than the reason for every
single time no matter how big your
circle it is I first moved a small or
six point two eight to something wrong
maybe six point two eight three so it's
sort of just a result that we get from
measuring these and seeing it's the
number that we keep for that ratio the
relationship between that round lay and
that's right is always going to be the
same so yeah every single time no matter
how big or small the circle is which is
kind of we get a perplexing but it's
true it's true at least it's easy to
learn
did you ever question to find their
circumference you do - hmm so that's
actually how is doing it mentally so for
instance suppose you did measure this
and I'm straight lines are really easy
to measure right and suppose we did
measure it with 15 centimeters if you
then wanted to know the circumference
was without doing the cut out stream
straight thing that I talked about you
can say all the circumference will be 2
times pi times 15 centimeters which just
to tell you like an actual memory
the only problem with this is and I
don't know where the buttons are now
this stuff doesn't help because it
actually just says 30 Pi which is not
very helpful
someone going together lady I'm Russian
arms right be on fire yes it's a good
question and the reason why I let me
just write down this number I get ninety
four point remember what I said before
about experiment all points we label
yeah yeah cool tape it up about taking a
whole bunch of circles I actually drove
them up and putting some string around
which I hope you year seven teachers
actually do in here once upon a time
okay you can drop a table for yourself
like this will probably look something
like this we never in this or something
you'd go I can't measure the radius what
do you get measure the circumference
what do you go and then you'd say well
okay let's just see zero Nicias which is
let's divide one by the other okay you
get you know ninety four point two sorry
I don't have ninety four point two and
fifteen I wonder what happens when you
divide you do another circle right you
go okay well with radius 10 and you get
about 63 when you measure you're like I
wonder what I'll get the number that you
keep getting is two times five which
seems like it's a weird coincidence to
have they say when something happens
once it's set happens twice it's a bit
of a coincidence but if you can do this
a million times you keep
to say no it's Lauren Quinton anymore
it's a pattern yeah